i'm calling on president dick to resign
um because i think that we need action
to be taken to restore the bond of trust
that there should be between women and
the police who are supposed to make them
safe we need determined action we need
committed leadership to take those
changes through and cressida dick has
shown that she is not the person who can
lead those changes so it's not just to
make a symbolic point that i think that
she should step down it's to make way
for the changes that need to happen and
really be
driven through
so that women can once again have
confidence
the poor the point some people make
though is that if cressida dick resigns
this won't change anything this is a
systemic issue is it not this is about
misogyny toxic masculinity uh
the kind of
actions that we we know that other
police officers have carried out and
offenses carried out by other police
officers this this is a systemic issue
this is not a personal issue for
cressida dick
well indeed it is a systemic issue and
she has been in charge of the system
and complaints have been made in the
past for example by the center for
women's justice reports have come out
from an example by the police
inspectorate
even after even as late as after
sarah's killer admitted to killing her
she could have taken some of the actions
which would have begun to restore
confidence but to be starting to talk
about learning lessons is to completely
miss
what her job in leadership is and there
are some very very clear actions which
i'm calling for to happen right away
which are absolutely blindingly obvious
that need to be taken and she is not the
person to take them through if she
thinks that we need to just start
learning lessons at this point and that
she's presided over a system where
people have said there are problems and
she's failed to act i i want to come to
some of the measures that you've
suggested in a moment but if we stick
with the dame crescendo dick for the
moment uh
uh why now why specifically are you
calling for her resignation now
her career
has famously a number of misdemeanors
and and courted controversy way back to
jean charles de menezes
because i'm thinking of all the women
and indeed the fathers and the brothers
and
all the the men who are concerned about
women and all the women themselves
looking at those video clips looking at
a police officer using his
power of arrest which he has as an
officer of the metropolitan police in
order to kidnap and abduct sarah everard
using his handcuffs issued by the
metropolitan police
um they have seen that and their
confidence is rocked i mean cressida
dick talks about the police being rocked
by
what's happened its public confidence
has been rocked to to destruction in
this and therefore we need to have
somebody who recognizes that this is not
just a roman that's what she said
abaddon no she said abaddon this is the
occasional baden
this is not an occasional baden this is
a systemic problem she has presided over
the system and it's no good her saying
the met is a wonderful and organization
full of dedicated people and this was
one bad apple that is not the sort of
person we need we need somebody who's
going to recognize the systems need to
change to make sure that this can't
happen again
uh looking let's turn to some of these
suggestions you've made in your letter
to uh pretty patel uh it's interesting
you took the very words out of my mouth
you you've called them yourself
blindingly obvious and when i was
reading them
it kind of beggars belief that these are
not already in place for the benefit of
the viewer i'll read a few if an
allegation is of violence against a
woman has been made against a serving
officer he must be or she must be
suspended uh there must be a new rule
that uh
immediate suspension of any officer
against whom an allegation of violence
uh is made but a
um conviction or admission of an offense
of violence against a woman against
women by an officer must immediately be
dismissed from the force uh they are
blindingly obvious why have they not
been in place before why have
politicians like yourself and others not
implemented these
well they should have been in place
before and including um if i could say
that colleagues who cover up for a
fellow officer that should be regarded
as gross misconduct and they should be
dismissed
that when an officer is transferring him
from another force
instead of just taking it uh that he's
uh got no allegations against him the
force where he's coming to work needs to
check him again they need to sort out
and improve the vetting and screening
procedures for new recruits so that they
probe the question of their attitude to
male violence to women
whether they use
online hard porn whether they engage in
um
violence during sex we can't have women
looking to police officers who actually
are not as president dick herself said
there to protect them
be trustworthy and be compassionate
the the screening and vetting process
for new recruits is not good enough but
also for existing officers there needs
to be a compulsory training for all
existing officers so that they can
examine their own attitudes about male
violence towards women and also how to
spot the signs in their colleagues so if
you have a zero tolerance program
which in any other organization
the idea that somebody would commit a
decent assault and expose themselves and
that their colleagues would cover up i
mean they would all be dismissed and yet
the culture in the police
as it as it has been has enabled that to
happen and that does bring a stain not
only um on those individuals but all the
other good officers who want the police
to be such that women can trust them
uh while you've been speaking we've just
had a a
a statement come through to us harriet
harman from the met police so i'll just
read that to one of the points in it
for everyone watching it says that
cousins wayne cousins was a serving and
vetted police officer when he joined the
met
he had no criminal convictions or
cautions
and he was not subject to any misconduct
proceedings during his time at the met i
mean
for me straight off the bat that that
striking given that we know that he was
a man
known amongst the metropolitan police by
colleagues as the rapist harriet harman
well when he was working for the civil
nuclear constabulary he was known um
amongst colleagues as the rapist when he
um was in the kent contemporary there
were allegations against him and there
were further allegations
not long before he abducted raped and
murdered sarah
that uh that he'd exposed himself and it
really is no good to say oh he was
vetted it's no good to defend the
processes
the processes have allowed
the absolute horrifying tragedy of sarah
everard to be killed and this is
precisely what the problem is with
cressida dick she is going on the
defensive she should go on the front
foot to say
i completely understand how awful this
is and how this has not only rocked the
police it has rocked the confidence of
women in the in the metropolitan women
in london and i am going to act on it
and here is all the things that i am
going to do
you know i'm going to have zero
tolerance we're going to have training
for all serving officers we're going to
have a new vetting procedure for receipt
recruits one strike and you will be out
cover up for your colleagues and you
will be out allegation against you and
you will be immediately suspended
independent investigation by a different
force not by your mates these are all
things which she could be saying and
instead she's saying
well what is she saying and nothing that
can give anybody any confidence so i
mean i've been a member of parliament
for nearly 40 years in london i've never
called for a metropolitan commissioner
to resign because i i want to help
people improve our public services not
just say heads must roll but i really
cannot see how president dick can lead
the change that we need